actress ellie kemper trends on twitter
as a kkk princess despite zero evidence
of racism
as president biden declares a democracy
in danger democrats in texas attempt to
stop it from working and seek federal
intervention
and officials worry the democratic
policy will spur a bloody summer i'm ben
shapiro this is the bench bureau show
[Music]
today's show is sponsored by
expressivevpn don't let bigtech track
what you do anonymize your web browsing
at expressvpn.com
ben we'll get to all the news in just
one moment first your reminder today
that you should be saving money on your
cell phone bill like
today another thousand of you my
extremely wise listeners have made the
switch from your overpriced wireless
carrier to pure talk over the past
couple of months so what are the rest of
you waiting for
if you're with att verizon or t-mobile
your family could save over 800
a year just by switching to pure talk
you get the same great coverage because
they use the exact same towers as one of
the big carriers you can even keep your
phone and your number but you will save
a fortune
by the way puretalk is the top-rated
wireless company by consumer affairs
they've got the absolute best customer
service team based right here
in america if that sounds good it gets
even better because right now you can
get unlimited
talk text and six gigs of data for just
30 bucks a month and if you go over on
this data
they don't charge you for it grab your
mobile phone sell pound 250 say ben
shapiro to get started today when you do
you save fifty percent off your very
first month dial pound two five zero say
keyword ben
shapiro to get started pure talk is
simply smarter wireless why would you
be spending a ton of money on your cell
phone bill when you really don't have to
you could be saving hundreds of bucks a
year
simply by switching over to pure tactile
pound 250 say ben shapiro join thousands
of my listeners who've already done so
save
50 off your very first month of pure
talk usa
coverage alrighty so right now one of
the things we're watching politically in
the united states
is this attempt to play up the idea that
america is a deeply racist place
and here's the problem for a lot of
folks on the left they look around and
they say okay well america actually is
not all that racist
here's the reality if you look at other
countries around the globe america is
far less
racist than those countries if you look
at countries in asia america is way less
racist
countries in europe america is way less
racist in fact america is one of the
least racist
places on earth and if you cite lot
chapter and verse
about all of the people in the united
states of minority races
who have risen to unbelievable heights
in the united states including the
current vice president of the united
states or the former president of the
united states or the former attorney
general of the united states
supreme court justices of the united
states if you point out that black
americans
have the highest household income in the
united states of any black people
anywhere on planet earth in any country
if you point this out if you point out
that income mobility does in fact
exist for every american if they make
simple and basic decisions about how to
better their own lives like don't have
babies out of wedlock finish high school
and get a job if you point that out
this sort of undermines the case that is
made consistently by the left that
america is a deeply racist place see it
used to be at the left claim that
america was in the midst of a class
crisis and this required a complete
redistribution of wealth and required
the systems to be torn down
well now since that didn't work out
because it turns out that america's
income mobility is amazing that you can
become
middle class and your kids can become
wealthy in the united states with again
a modicum of effort and responsible
decision-making as a general rule not
for everybody but as a general rule
the class-based war that has taken place
in the united states
on behalf of the left has shifted into a
race-based war in the united states on
behalf of the left and the argument here
is that america is
deeply racist today now again the
problem is when you look at the stats
what you see
is that people of all races in the
united states are capable of succeeding
so instead what we have shifted into is
a different argument and that argument
is that american history is replete with
racism and therefore all differences
in group outcome today can be chalked up
to historic
mistreatment now there are a couple
problems with this argument
problem number one is that it would
require some sort of quantification how
much of today's problems are due to
history
and how much of today's problems are due
to decision making
in the here and now and i'm not asking
whether the decision-making in the here
and now
to which you have agency if that is
impacted by your history because the
reality of life is that everybody's
decision making
is impacted by the history of their
family going back since the beginning of
human history the question is did you
have the capacity to do otherwise
and the answer when it comes to most
basic decisions in the united states is
yes you did and so if you try to
quantify that the argument that history
is responsible
for all of group differences in the
united states today is not a
particularly good argument it is not a
particularly effective argument
and so what this has left people with is
the bifurcated spectacle
of on the one hand a democratic party
that seeks radical change in the united
states claiming
that historic racism in the united
states is so deep and so all pervasive
that no matter what kind of decisions
you attempt to make today you won't
succeed which is a lie
or on the other hand that racism still
is a deep part of every aspect
of american life and needs to be rooted
out that really today's systems are in
fact racist now again
neither of these arguments is
particularly compelling because if you
look
in the united states at a variety of
groups who have been mistreated across
american history and sure black
americans
granted and true have been mistreated
more than any other american group in
american life
and there are explicit systems of
discrimination that were embedded in law
and designed in law against black
americans all the way up until the civil
rights act 1964.
it's also been 60 years since the civil
rights act of 1964
which in sort of generational
parliaments is three generations
but that can all be true it's also true
that discrimination has taken place
against asian americans in american life
in deep and abiding ways and yet asian
americans have the highest household
income
of any income group in the united states
it's true that anti-anti-semitism was a
deep part of american life
really all the way up until the 1960s
even today jews are the most
discriminated against group in the
united states on the basis of hate
crimes
and yet jews have extraordinary
household income in the united states
in fact when we're talking about black
americans who are not what we would call
american descendants of slavery
right there's a term that's used in
social science when we're talking about
say west indian blacks who have come to
the united states over the course of the
last 40 years or if you're talking about
jamaican blacks have come to the united
states
over the course of the last 40 years or
so those groups perform very well in the
united states in fact the single highest
educated group in the united states
right now i believe are nigerian
americans right who are black by skin
color
so the question is why you would say
that america's institutions today are
racist when they are pretty clearly not
racist
today so that argument doesn't really
hold a lot of scrutiny so what's
happening right now is because
race does have much more of a history in
the united states in terms of
being an obstacle to progress and and
racism being an obstacle
to the american ideal then does class
the left is still clinging to it
and so the demand for racism is
currently outstripping the supply the
truth is on a day-to-day level in the
united states there is just
not a lot of racism again on a relative
level this is not to deny that racism
occurs it's not to deny that there are
bad people out there who are racist
it is too it is to point out that if you
are calling for
world-breaking change if you're calling
for all the systems of the united states
to be overthrown
and redone you need a really big crisis
in order to make that happen
last year the democrats used covet as
the crisis in order to push that forward
and now covet is waning and so they're
running out of steam on that one
they've attempted to use income
inequality but most people don't
actually see income inequality as a
crisis
they may see it as a problem they don't
see it as a crisis in fact most
americans don't really care all that
much
about what their neighbor is earning
they tend to care a lot more about what
they are earning
but the race crisis is something that
the media have latched on to and it
turns out
that if that is not a crisis if most
americans
are happy to live side by side with
people of other races and aren't
discriminating in their day-to-day life
against people of other races the demand
for racism
outstrips the supply the demand for a
lot of racism in society so that you can
tear down the systems and say the
systems themselves
must be extirpated in order to
substitute a quote unquote less racist
system
you need a lot of racism to make that
case and that racism
just is not all pervasive it just is not
and so the media are going to play up
everything i'll bring you today's latest
ridiculous example of this in just
one second first let's talk about the
fact that if you're looking to save
money on your mortgage
you may not have much time left it's
true the historically low interest rates
we've gotten used to
are slightly rising as of late but
they're still low enough that many
homeowners can benefit
in fact 13 million homeowners are still
eligible for almost 300
in monthly savings is that you a good
way of finding out is by calling
american financing for a free mortgage
review
i mean it it's free there's no
obligation no upfront or hidden fees no
pressure just a simple conversation
around low rate loan programs that will
customize solutions and you'll choose
what you like it could mean up to a
thousand dollars in monthly savings and
you could postpone
two mortgage payments you have to call
american financing to get started today
and you have to do it right now
before rates get any higher 866-721-3300
that is 866-721-3300 or visit
americanfinancing.net that's american
financing
nmls one eight two three three four
mls consumer access dot org again you
could save hundreds of bucks a month on
your mortgage why wouldn't you do so go
check out my friends over at american
financing
give them a call 866 721 3300 or visit
americanfinancing.net that's
americanfinancing.net okay so again
if you want to create the case for huge
change in the united states
you need to make one of two cases one is
that historic racism
is the great driver of today's
discrepancies
okay and to do that you would have to
ignore all of the intervening factors
all of american history you'd have to
ignore the fact that a huge
reason for discrepancies and individual
performance is individual decision
making
you'd have to ignore the idea that
people have agency which they very
clearly do
and one one fact that i continuously
state when i taught when it comes to
intergenerational poverty and
differences between black and white and
intergenerational poverty
is the fact that single motherhood
remains perhaps
in all likelihood the greatest indicator
of intergenerational poverty in american
life and 70
of black kids are born without a father
in the home and when people say well
that's the effect of american racism you
then have to ask why it is
that the beginning of the 20th century
black americans were getting married at
higher rates than white americans and in
black americans had a 20 illegitimacy
rate as opposed to today and over 70
illegitimate rates did racism get worse
between 1960
and 2021 the answer pretty obviously is
no
okay so that means you need to
make the case that racism is all over
the place today
and this is how you end up with ellie
kemper trending on twitter hey ellie
kemper is an actress you saw her
in the office you saw her in that
amazon show the unbreakable kimmy
schmidt i think was the name of the show
and now she is trending on twitter why
is ellie kemper trending
she is trending as a quote-unquote kkk
princess
i am not kidding you this is they're
trending her as a kkk princess
because some idiot blue check marks have
declared her thus
what did ellie kemper do that's so
terrible well apparently
back in 1991 1999 when she was 19 years
old
she was the veiled she was the queen of
the veiled prophet ball
in st louis now you may say to yourself
what the hell's a veiled profit ball i
have no idea what that is
well if you just read the twitter
headlines it was a kkk ball in which a
bunch of
clan clansmen got together and they
honored ellie kemper as the queen of the
kkk
and i'm not kidding this is how it's
being treated on twitter okay the
reality is
that the quote-unquote veiled profit
ball was created in 1878
okay and it didn't have anything
explicitly to do with the clan
in fact the entire history of the of the
veiled prophet ball is that it was sort
of like a weird pageant
that was dreamed up by this guy who was
attempting to generate
some sort of attention for st louis he'd
gone down to new orleans he teamed mardi
gras he wanted to create some sort of
event
that looked like mardi gras and then
infuse it with some sort of
strange irish mythology based on the
poetry of a guy named thomas moore
okay so this created in 1878 it becomes
sort of a city
hallmark basically and then for the next
150 years
every year there's a girl at the at the
event who's chosen as the queen now what
exactly does this have to do
with la kemper being a racist the answer
is nothing there's no evidence that
ellie kemper's racist at all
but because in the atlantic there's a
piece in 2014
about the veiled prophet paul and the
history of the veil profit ball and
because it took place again
starting in missouri in 1878 when there
were a lot of confederates
but people had served in the confederate
army and people who were racist
who were associated with the beginning
of the ball this means that ellie kemper
today
in like 1999 not only in 1999 in 2021
22 years later is a racist and ellie
kemper what's a trend
on twitter so again what did what
exactly is this veiled profit ball
according to this article that's being
passed around in the atlantic
in 1878 grain executive and former
confederate cavalryman charles slayback
called the meeting of local business and
civic leaders his intention was to form
a secret society that would blend the
pomp and ritual of a new orleans mardi
gras
with the symbolism used by the irish
poet thomas moore from moore's poetry
slayback and the st
louis elite created the myth of the
veiled prophet of coruscant a mystic
traveler who inexplicably decided to
make st louis
his base of operations a person would be
chosen by a secret local board
of elites to anonymously play the role
of the veiled prophet the veiled prophet
would choose a queen of love and beauty
from among the elite ball attendees with
whom he would dance a royal quadrille
before presenting her with an expensive
keepsake such as the tiara or pearls
in october 1878 they had their first
parade which attracted more than 50 000
spectators so why exactly did they do
this well number one
st louis was competing with chicago so
they wanted some sort of big event
to push back against chicago
and number two they were trying to
apparently respond to
labor unrest in the city involving
cooperation between white and black
workers okay so now we're going back to
like
labor issues in 1877 to say why ellie
kemper today
is a racist for having received an award
in 1999.
by the way worth noting that other
prominent people who have been
associated
with the with the veiled profit ceremony
include
harry truman okay so th
this is such a stretch okay it's an
unbelievable stretch
that ellie kemper is some sort of racist
also her family is very wealthy
okay which apparently is very bad you're
not allowed to have a wealthy family and
be an actress
apparently which is unfortunate news for
probably half of hollywood
but again this is a national story now
because people are bored
and they have to come up with incidents
of racism that are going to keep
generating the idea that historic racism
has its fangs in american life today
now still have they shown that ali kemp
is a racist or that anyone who gave her
an award in 99 was racist or that her
parents are racist
they've shown none of these things
doesn't matter she trends anyway
a similar sort of thing happening in the
la times today the la times
has a piece called a fight over jim crow
road divides rural northern california
town now you might say to yourself
well yeah that's weird that there's a
road named after jim crow except for the
fact
that this jim crow is not jim crow as in
like segregation jim crow this jim crow
was a native hawaiian
who came as a gold rush pioneer to a
mountainous swath of sierra county to
strike it rich according to the
to the l.a times his name was given to a
ravine a stream and a street off scenic
highway 49
three miles east of downeyville
california generations later
people who own property along the less
than a mile long road including a small
mountain resort say that jim crow has
got to go
so they are talking about renaming this
road not because
this jim crow had anything to do with
like jim crow
but because people could get offended
because they don't know
so instead of just explaining it they're
just going to get rid of the name of the
road now
listen you can name the whatever you
want it doesn't really matter the bottom
line is that if you're getting agitated
over a road name not after jim crow
name not after segregation let me
suggest that the big problem in your
life is not the name of the road that is
not named after jim crow
but again this all goes to a broader
media narrative
that suggests that america has to be it
must be
deeply racist because if it's not deeply
racist how are we going to push forward
this unprecedented change
how are we going to do this okay and you
see this coming all the way from the
white house right
this argument is made and then the
argument is applied to how we ought to
do public policy in the united states
which is why all this stuff matters
otherwise who cares that ellie kemper is
trending on twitter but they want to
rename a road in l.a i get it like no
one cares
okay but the reason that the media keep
pushing they keep
beating this particular drum is because
it is the impetus for the kind of change
that they have been seeking
a racist change from the top of american
government in terms of policy that is
overtly pro-discrimination we'll get to
that in just one second first
between father's day flag day national
yo-yo day the month of june
there's a lot going on thankfully policy
genius makes it easy to cross life
insurance off your list so you can back
to yo-yoing if someone relies on your
financial support if you're talking
about a child aging parent even a
business partner
you need life insurance policy genius
makes it easy to compare quotes from
over a dozen top insurers all in one
place why compare well you could save 50
or more on life insurance by comparing
quotes with policy genius you could say
1300 bucks or more per year on life
insurance by using policy genius to
compare policies the licensed experts at
policy genius work for you not the
insurance
companies so you can trust them to help
you navigate every step of the shopping
and buying process that kind of service
has earned policy genius an excellent
rating on trustpilot getting started
super simple first head on over to
policygenius.com
shapiro in minutes you can work out how
much life insurance coverage you need
and compare personalized quotes to find
your best price
when you're ready to apply that policy
genius team will handle the paperwork
and the scheduling for free
policy genius never sells your
information to other companies they
don't add on extra fees head on over to
policygenius.com
shapiro to get started right now policy
genius when it comes to insurance it's
nice and incredibly important
to get it right alrighty so again the
narrative is that america is deeply
racist
and there are two ways that this has
been applied to repeat one is america's
history is racist there's a lot of hit
racism in american history for sure
and there and therefore the argument
goes that because america's history has
a lot of racism in it this is what
explains discrepancies today
that argument does not follow and the
second is that america's institutions
today
are thoroughly poisoned and people are
secretly racist that racism is actually
worse
because it's sort of under the surface
today and again that argument
really is very hard to substantiate but
this is the argument made by the
democratic party so
joe biden today he's headed over to
tulsa oklahoma he's going to commemorate
the
100 year anniversary commemoration of
of probably the worst race riot in
american history the 1921
tulsa race massacre he has declared
may 31 2021 a day of remembrance now it
is well worth remembering he the telstra
race massacre
a lot of people have only become
familiar with the tulsa race massacre in
the recent past
and good i'm glad that people are now
more aware of it it is a
deep and important point in american
history it demonstrates the lengths to
which white racists would go
in order to damage black people in 1921
it is now 2021. okay the tulsa race
massacre
which is shown in the opening scenes of
hbo's watchmen took place basically
after
there was a false accusation apparently
false by every available metric of a
black man sexually assaulting a white
woman in an elevator
and then he was arrested he was put in
jail and then a bunch of white people
descended on the jail a bunch of black
world war one veterans showed up to stop
the lynching of this guy and it turned
into a full-scale frenzy race massacre
people were literally flying
planes over the black areas of tulsa and
they were dropping turpentine bombs and
burning down building i mean it's
unbelievable
it's incredible and it is well worthy of
remembrance but the point is not
remembering tulsa for democrats right
now the point of course is to suggest
that america has not changed since 1920
since 1921 in any real and fundamental
way
which is kind of what joe biden
basically says in his in his
proclamation yesterday
so joe biden put out a proclamation
about the tulsa race massacre
he called on americans to reflect on the
deep roots of racial terror in our
nation and recommit to the work of
rooting out systemic racism across our
country notice the connection
right here's something that happened in
2021 and it's super bad
and also it's happening today because
the roots of systemic racism
are in all of our institutions this is
the critical race theory argument
biden said the federal government must
reckon with and acknowledge the role
that it has played
in stripping wealth and opportunity from
black communities like is playing now
because that's really what you want to
talk about right is the fed how is the
federal government
hurting black people today right what
policies of the federal government are
designed to hurt black people today
that's been federally illegal since
1964. okay
again i checked my calendar it is not
1921 and it is 1964. this does not mean
there is not racism in the united states
for the thousandth time of course there
are racists in the united states but to
suggest the systems of the united states
in 2021
are racist in the way that systems of
the united states were racist in 1921
is to be absolutely outside reality
so what exactly is joe biden pushing on
the back of this he says the
biden-harris administration
is committed to acknowledging the role
federal policy played in greenwood and
other black communities and addressing
long-standing racial inequities through
historic investments in the economic
security of children and families
programs to provide capital for small
business and economically disadvantaged
areas including minority-owned
businesses
and ensuring that infrastructure
projects increase opportunity advance
racial equity and environmental justice
and
promote affordable access there you go
so bottom line is
there's a massacre a horror a horrifying
evil race massacre in 1921 in tulsa
oklahoma
and therefore we need affirmative action
programs in 2021
and therefore we need a vast
redistribution of wealth in 2021
and therefore we need a revolution from
the inside of american government to
quell the effects of racism
from 100 years ago now again the reason
that they're they're going to the well
on this one the reason why we are doing
all of this is not because joe biden has
a deep and abiding interest in american
history
it's because joe biden wants some
rationale for doing what he is doing
so don't buy when the case the left
makes is that
if you then push against what joe biden
is doing it's because you want to ignore
american racism of the past
no i'm very much in favor of
re-examining and exposing american
racism of the past
the question is what policy today is
best effectuated
to protect the individual rights and
success of all americans because the
answer to racism
was never racism the answer to racism
was never discrimination
the answer to racism was equal
protection of the laws
under the 14th amendment of the united
states constitution
but this is not the case that's being
made by the democrats the case that's
being made by the democrats is that we
have to skew
all the individual rights systems of the
united states because those individual
rights systems
were themselves racist this is the case
critical race theory makes it's the case
biden is making it's the case democrats
are making
they need the crisis in order to
generate the impetus for the kind of
change
they are seeking okay so the case made
by the democrats of course
is that if you if you disagree
then this is because you want to ignore
history which of course is not true
we'll get to that in just one moment
first summer is almost here that means
father's day is around the corner omaha
steaks it's not just steak it is the
best
steak of your life and this is the
greatest father's day gift
you can give guaranteed visit
omahastakes.com
keyword shapiro order the get out and
grill assortment today send dad
more than just a gift send me an
experience he'll love and can share it
with you go to omahasteaks.com
type shapiro in that search bar order to
add the get out and grill assortment
and what exactly does that include get
ready for this 20 entrees he's
guaranteed to love ultra juicy burgers
plum chicken breasts sides desserts
four 10-ounce butchers cut new york
strips the strips are aged for 30 days
why is that important because age equals
tenderness plus
you get four free new york strip burgers
with your order they're ultra lean they
pack a bold intense flavor don't forget
for a limited time get four free new
york strip burgers with your order that
is omahasteaks.com
keyword shapiro a few years back omaha
steaks went out and got me because i'm
special a kosher steak let me just tell
you
omaha knows what they are doing my
goodness mouth-watering stuff
so good it doesn't get better than that
on father's day imagine your dad opening
up that package
and seeing omaha steaks omahastakes.com
keyword shapiro
and make sure you get that deal pretty
awesome stuff alrighty so
in the argument made by the democrats is
that world-breaking change
has to be built on the back of arguments
made about things that happened a
hundred years ago
so michael buschloss who's effectively
the the official historian
of the biden administration here he is
on msnbc saying
that if you don't agree with joe biden's
attempts to use history as a cudgel to
wield against american systems today
it's because you want to ignore history
nope perfectly happy to recognize the
flaws and evils of american history
if you are willing to recognize the good
and fundamental fundamentally true
principles of the declaration of
independence and constitution of the
united states
i don't think the left's willing to make
that trade
many americans think that if something
terrible happens
the best way to be patriotic is to try
to forget about it as soon as possible
and this is something i'm even worried
about in a totally different category
our pandemic with kovid in uh
in 1920 after the influenza
pandemic that killed 675 000
americans tens of millions of others
around the world
americans the second the pandemic seemed
to be over
they wanted to forget about it as soon
as possible okay again it's
historic ignorance michael schloss is
going to lecture you about it
because if you don't agree with joe
biden's agenda it's because you want to
remain historically ignorant
or we could point out that last year we
had riots that caused 2 billion
in damage in the united states these
were largely race riots
and that nobody wants to pay attention
to that well democrats including the
vice president of the united states were
openly fomenting
some of this violence i mean i don't
know what else you would call it when
the vice president of the united states
then senator from california
was openly attempting to raise funds to
bail people out of jail for rioting
okay but we're supposed to pay attention
that apparently has less impact on
today's life than 1921 the tulsa race
massacre and none of this is to say we
shouldn't
again we should pay attention to the
tulsa race massacre and then we should
point out that racism lurks in every
human heart and that
it is our job as individual human beings
to fight that
to appeal to the better angels of our
nature and also we should acknowledge
that a few things have changed since
1921.
okay but here is joe biden's actual
agenda so biden is visiting tulsa
oklahoma today
according to cnn he's going to deliver
remarks to memorialize the hundreds of
black americans who were killed by a
white mob that had attacked their
neighborhood and burned dozens of city
blocks
to the ground what is the actual goal
here he's expected to announce new steps
to help minority-owned businesses grow
and to address racial discrimination in
the housing market
and here is here's how it goes the
president will announce he will use
federal purchasing power to grow federal
contracting with small disadvantaged
businesses many of them minority owned
by 50 right he's not openly going to say
that we're just going to give
a bunch of money to black owned
businesses but that's what this means
right when he says that he wants
small disadvantaged businesses to be
given loans basically he's talking about
a suburb prime mortgage
except applied not to minority
homeowners
but applied instead to minority
businesses sponsored by the federal
taxpayer
the white house said this will translate
to an additional hundred billion dollars
over five years
he'll also announce new specifics on the
10 billion community revitalization fund
included in his infrastructure proposal
the fund will be targeted to
economically underserved and
underdeveloped communities like
greenwood where the massacre took place
a century ago
the fund will support adapting vacant
buildings and storefronts to provide
low-cost space for services and
community entrepreneurs
including health centers arts and
cultural spaces job training programs
business incubators and community
marketplaces it will also support
removing toxic waste to create new parks
and community gardens
also he's going to declare a new
interagency effort to address inequity
in home appraisal
and to aggressively combat housing
discrimination
the department is moving toward
traditional interpretations of the fair
housing act apparently he's going to
direct his hud secretary marcia fudge to
lead an interagency initiative to
address inequity in home appraisals this
initiative
will include carrying out potential
enforcement under fair housing laws
regulatory action and the development of
standards and guidance in partnership
with industry and state
and local governments also new tax
credits
okay so again the idea here from
democrats is what if we poured a bunch
of money
into these downtrodden areas which of
course are downtrodden because of
historic racism
you know who tried this lbj lbj poured
literally trillions of dollars over the
course of the last
50 60 years in the united states we've
poured over 20 trillion dollars into war
on poverty programs disproportionately
targeted minority communities and lbj
was quite open
about the way that he saw this he saw it
as a form of racial reparations which
again
in 1964 made a lot more sense than it
does in 2021 but joe biden is just
lbj part two he's just lbj on steroids
and again he's the and the case that
he's going to make is that racism has
not abated since the 1960s
that historic racism that the gap
between 1921 and 1964
which again was only 43 years is kind of
the same as the gap between 1921 and
2021.
this is the goal here and it's going to
be applied to every area of american
policy
so yesterday for example when he was not
pushing
today he'll be pushing the business loan
allocation on the basis of race
he's going to be pushing housing
appraisal on the basis
of race presumably he's going to be
promoting all of this sort of stuff
right that is his goal
but it's not just that the biden
administration is using this as an
excuse to federalize all voting law
so yesterday on memorial day and then
we're supposed to be paying tribute to
the fallen
soldiers who have given the last full
measure of devotion for their country
uh a fact that should leave us in awe
and should remind us of the freedoms for
which they fought
instead joe biden used memorial day not
just to pay tribute which he did but
also to then
turn and use that tribute as a way to
club his political opposition
so he said the democracy is in peril at
home this is what he was saying on
memorial day yesterday now let's be real
about this democracy is not in peril at
home
okay i understand a lot of people
including me thought that the sites of
january 6 were egregious
and abhorrent and disgusting also
democracy was not in peril
it was not the election was certified
all the people who did what they were
supposed to do did what they were
supposed to do
they went and they voted and they
certified the election more people voted
in the last elections i know we're
supposed to forget all this
there was greater turnout in last last
year's election cycle than any election
in american history in absolute numbers
and an extraordinarily high percentage
turned out as well
we had something like 155 million people
vote in the united states that does not
look like democracy imperil to me we're
not at risk
of syrian style democracy with 95 of
people voting for one party or another
doesn't matter here is joe biden
suggesting that democracy is in peril
here at home democracy itself
is in peril here at home and around the
world
what we do now what we do now
how we honor the memory of the fallen
will determine whether or not democracy
will long endure
we all take it for granted we think we
learn in school you have to every
generation has to fight for it
okay so what does he mean by that he
means that texas is passing a voting law
texas attempted to pass a voting law
this voting law is not in fact a wildly
discriminatory law despite the fact that
joe biden is going to portray it as such
the goal here for joe biden is to say
that democracy is in danger
it's in danger from a bunch of white
racists and you need me to solve all of
those problems give me and the federal
government more power over your lives
so you need to in order to avoid
authoritarianism what you need to do is
pass all of your power to a federal
government to run every aspect of your
life
if that sounds like a bad deal to you
that's because you've been following the
argument here is joe biden ripping on
the voting laws in texas
democracy thrives when the
infrastructure of democracy is strong
when people have the right to vote
freely and fairly and conveniently
when a free and independent press
pursues the truth
founded on facts not propaganda
when the rule of law applies equally and
fairly to every citizen
regardless of where they come from what
they look like
i mean it's just orwellian stuff from
president house plans over here when the
media operate freely and fairly
and the media are in his corner and
social media shut down stories
that are unpalatable to the biden
administration
when people can vote freely and fairly
right now he's attempting to federalize
election law
i mean it it truly is incredible stuff
again remember that this is
a ploy it's a ploy cast america in the
worst possible light so you can call for
radical change to the united states that
is what joe biden is doing
right now now what does that mean in
practical terms well it means in texas
an anti-democratic move so the same
people who are complaining that
democracy is under threat
they just walked out of a session in
texas to stop a law from being passed
this is the texas
voter law what exactly does that
encompass according to the wall street
journal
as the texas legislative session drew
near its end on sunday lawmakers
appeared set to pass a bill overhauling
the state's elections until democrats
did one final maneuver
they sneaked out of the building members
take your key and leave the chamber
discreetly a democratic leader in the
state house told his caucus in a 10 35
pm text message
the extraordinary move deprived the
house of a quorum killing the bill for
now at the cost of undermining the
legislative process
but what do you expect after months of
democratic alarms about voter
suppression
president biden on saturday called the
texas plan un-american and part of an
assault on democracy
now he had already said that georgia's
law was like jim crow which of course is
insane
the reality according to the wall street
journal is more prosaic to start with
the controversial the 67-page bill would
roll back coven-19 innovations like
harris county's drive-through voting in
24-hour voting
those options were used
disproportionately last year by black
and hispanic residents but when did
emergency procedures amid a 100 year
pandemic suddenly become the new
baseline
it's hardly crazy to think polling place
shenanigans might be more likely at 3 am
the bill also says that on the last
sunday of early voting polling places
may not open until 1 pm
this is a political mistake at minimum
in that it's being spun as an attack on
black churches that have a souls to the
polls tradition
one lawmaker supporting the bill argued
those election workers want to go to
church too
but some people take care of their
religious obligations on saturdays and
in any event texas repealed most of its
blue laws in 1985
lawmakers would be wise to drop this
provision texas still
offers two weeks of early voting
delaware doesn't have any early voting
until 2022 and then it'll get 10 days
the texas bill raises the number of
minimum hours
mail ballots and applications would ask
for a state id number or the last four
digits of a social security number
that of course is just to verify that
people are who they say they are
this notion that the that this bill is
somehow a racist
return to jim crow or an attempt to shut
down democracy it's just a lie from joe
biden
who again is the head of a party in
which texas democratic lawmakers
literally walked out of a chamber
to deny a quorum so that democracy could
not operate and then
called for the federal government to
intervene in state business
from the top meanwhile declaring
republicans the authoritarians
pretty amazing stuff the bill would
change the legal standard for improving
fraud from a preponderance of the
to a preponderance of the evidence from
clear and convincing evidence
if the number of illegal votes matched
the margin courts could throw out a race
without showing that fraud changed the
result
critics say this is a pandered trump but
trump lost in 2020 under either standard
whether the new rules are two lakhs is a
judgment call imagine a race decided by
50 votes with 51 illegal ballots
detected did more slip through
perhaps the best thing for public
confidence would be to redo the election
okay bottom line is that the attempt to
castigate this bill as something
horrifying
is ridiculous but this is exactly what
democrats are trying to do here's a
democratic representative named mark
vise over the weekend saying that this
bill is like zimbabwe
zimbabwe when you say that
you can overturn elect an election uh
based on
crazy tropes and racial stereotypes
about texas citizens uh it's just
absolutely
insane that they're even uh thinking
about that and so imagine
uh any close race that republicans
wanted to uh to go
uh and and and overturn they would be
able to do so with that provision
and that's not something that happens in
our country that's something that you
think about happening
you know in zimbabwe now he's speaking
currently he's speaking from the federal
congress where nancy pelosi
literally held up for months the seating
of an iowa congress person who was
elected by six votes in a republican
in a republican race okay she held it up
so this is all just power games and it's
all masks for power games
and the mass that is currently being
adopted by the democrats is that
america's a deeply racist place just
look at american history
you don't have to pay attention to
what's happened in the intervening time
you don't have to pay attention
to america on the ground today
exacerbate racial divisions for purposes
of political game
that is the game right here already in
just a second
we'll get to more the biden
administration's push and
why this is going to result in more dead
people in the united states first
if you want to be part of stopping the
leftist power grab currently underway in
america
i wrote the book for you we've been
talking about the rise of
authoritarianism
it is the rise of authoritarianism on
the left that provides the greatest
threats to the country it's why i wrote
it the book
the authoritarian moment we're here to
help americans see the greater good
propaganda for what it is an
authoritarian power grab it does not end
in freedom in the authoritarian moment i
give background on how we got here and
tips on fighting back we go through
every institution
in american life from science to
education and we talk about how these
institutions were militarized and
weaponized by the left how they were
renormalized and
how we fight back which is really the
important part so if you want to
preserve your individual rights and
protect the ones you love from mob rule
go check out my book today the
authoritarian moment is now available
for pre-order at amazon
barnes and noble or any other major book
seller
comes out in july pre-order it now make
sure you get your copy
as soon as it's available the
authoritarian moment go check it out
right now you're listening to the
largest fastest growing conservative
podcast and radio show in the nation
[Music]
now recognize that the same left that is
pushing authoritarianism like draw
authoritarianism right they want a
federalized
voting procedure that violates all
federalist properties they want to
use discrimination as a tool of federal
government policy
and do so on the basis of historic
grievances
100 years old 60 years after the civil
rights act
and they want to remake all of america's
institutions call them all racists and
then run them from the top
with no input by you and seize your
taxpayer dollars to do so
the same people in the media and that
the media are covering for this of
course they're they're part and parcel
of the propaganda wing of the democratic
party they're focusing heavy in
on michael flynn now michael flynn has
not been a relevant political player
since he was nsa for five seconds at the
beginning of 2016.
they're trotting him out now because he
went to some sort of crazy conspiracy
conference and while he was there he
suggested
that we need some sort of move like
myanmar to reinstate president trump
as president or something and the media
are of course going bap leap over this
now
why why like is michael flynn a deeply
important person in american life at
this point
uh i don't think so but the media will
headline with this and not the actual
threat to your liberty
you know in terms of voting laws that
are being changed by the democrats at
the federal level
or in terms of the democrats actively
weaponizing the institutions
of education even even
sort of critical race theater in the
military like who has institutional
control
focus on the shiny object over here
michael flynn is what the media are
saying as opposed to you know the actual
threats to your day-to-day life
namely the government which is in fact
curtailing your liberties here's michael
flynn being an idiot
i want to know why what happened
in minamar can't happen
[Applause]
here
yeah no reason i mean it should happen
here no reason
right that's right okay so this was the
headline like the huffington post right
this is the big headline on the left
was a guy who has not been important in
the national conversation
and was prosecuted and then he was let
off
or he the deal was cutter charges were
dropped he was last relevant again in
late
2016. it is now 2021. meanwhile you have
joe biden actively promoting a complete
remaking of american government
spending 6 trillion yes
6 trillion a year on the american budget
for like the next decade
and trying to cut international deals to
crush
corporations and don't worry the
authoritarian left is michael flynn
speaking of that global tax so joe biden
according to the washington post
he's going to meet with the g7 and now
he's going to try to get all these other
countries
to boost their minimum corporate tax why
because he recognizes that his own
garbage corporate policy is going to
lead to businesses fleeing the united
states and investing elsewhere so now
he's attempting to build essentially an
economic berlin wall
and make sure that the only places that
everybody everyone else can do
go are under the umbrella of the same
corporate tax rate
according to the washington post finance
ministers from group of seven nations
meeting in london on friday are expected
to back president biden's call for a
global minimum tax on corporate profits
giving him an early win in a grueling
diplomatic campaign that is just
beginning
the new minimum tax one half of a
two-pronged global reform effort
is designed to halt a cycle of corporate
tax cutting that has sapped government
revenue
around the globe as part of a package
deal negotiators are also wrestling with
european demands to tax american
technology giants
such as google and facebook which earns
substantial revenue in countries where
they have little physical presence
biden catalyzed the global tax debate in
late may by proposing a worldwide
minimum tax of at least 15 percent
if he can secure agreement from the
world's leading democracies it could
eventually produce the most significant
global tax shift in decades putting a
floor beneath
multinationals tax bills in other
countries would help the president raise
the corporate tax rate at home to 28
by reducing the incentive for
corporations to continue shifting
hundreds of billions of dollars in
profits to low tax venues so he's going
to attempt to get other countries to
raise their taxes so that we can raise
our taxes
great all that means is that countries
uh by the way there will be countries
that just don't go along with this that
are not g7 countries
then guess what those countries will
reap the benefits of having done so
now meanwhile the same president who is
pushing for
racial equity continues to push for
less policing he continues to put at the
top of his doj
radical anti-police activists and then
he wonders why
there are wild increases in murder over
the course of the last year
and the media are finally starting to
notice headline in the washington post
today
officials worry the rise in violent
crime pretends a bloody summer
it's trauma on top of trauma well who
could who could have predicted
the mayor of albany never expected to
spend her days attending funerals and
comforting the families of those killed
and injured in a spate of alarming gun
violence she finds hard to explain
it shocks the conscience said kathy
sheehan and democrat
the disregard we are seeing for human
life it's trauma on top of trauma for
our city
eight people have been fatally shot in
york's capital city this year including
six
in may recently destiny green 15 was
killed in a quiet neighborhood a block
from the governor's mansion
after a group of men opened fire during
what police later said had been a
meet-up over a facebook marketplace ad
you haven't heard destiny green's name
until now because of course she wasn't
shot by the cops so her life apparently
doesn't matter according to black lives
matter
albany's violent crime spike is not an
outlier last weekend at least 12 mass
shootings occurred across united states
killing 11 people injuring at least 70
according to a database compiled by the
gun violence archive a nonprofit group
that tracks such incidents
the carnage included a shooting outside
a nightclub in minneapolis another two
were killed in a dozen injured
outside a house party in fairfield
township new jersey three were killed in
a shooting outside a bar in youngstown
ohio two people were killed and more
than 20 injured in miami area
after men with assault rifles and
handguns began shooting indiscriminately
into a crowd at a concert
early on sunday according to the police
as the nation marks memorial day the
unofficial beginning of summer many
officials are concerned this is a
preview of what they could face in
cities nationwide in coming months when
the onset of warm weather almost always
marks a rise in violent crime
so you want to know why you've seen a
rise in violent crime over the course of
the last year
the answer is because you decided to
crack down on the police and ignore
black lives matter violence throughout
america's major cities
it's the same thing after ferguson after
ferguson radical increase in crime
in the cities that were most targeted by
the feds you're about to see the same
thing happen
nationwide and it's hilarious to watch
as the media finally catch on to this
there's an entire article
in the seattle times today talking about
how portland has seen a seven-fold
increase in its homicide rate
and more portland residents have been
killed this year than in all of 2019.
not only that there's an entire article
in the washington post
about how anarchists and an increase in
violent crime have hijacked portland's
social justice movement well what if
they didn't hijack the social justice
movement what if they were part and
parcel of it what if ripping on the cops
and ripping on america's systems and
telling americans that their systems are
garbage and racist
leads to more violence and more
suffering all of which is then used by
democrats as an impetus for further
social change
who could have predicted such a thing
except everybody who's been watching
everybody who's been watching now here's
the
good news for the democrats the good
news is they still have this
unthreatening old man to trot out as the
face of all of this
so the the unthreatening old man is in
fact the key to this whole game for the
democrats
because waiting in the wings is kamal
harris who is certainly
unable to hide the radical agenda the
democrats have been pushing here
she is so off-putting there is a reason
why her approval ratings are wildly
underwater among independents
i mean she is way underwater she's like
a 41 approval rating i mean those are
abysmal approval ratings for a vice
president of a president who's well into
the 50s
there's a reason for it it's because
she's terrible over the weekend
kamala harris did an interview with mika
brzezinski on msnbc
and and the the msnbc crew is
just i mean when we talk about in the
tank they are in the tank i mean let me
begin with this
joe scarborough says that joe biden is
returning the united states to normalcy
which is just
insane i'm sorry there is no way that
joe biden has done anything to return
america to normalcy
if things if anything things have gotten
even more wild in terms of policy
the thing about donald trump is that his
policies were actually relatively normal
he himself in terms of personal behavior
not super normal his policies
pretty normal the biden administration
joe biden is wandering about
wandering into household objects and
knocking them over
he's chasing his dog and breaking his
foot by trying to grab its tail or
something but he's pushing
radical policy joe scarborough is in
favor of the radical policy so long as
it comes along with this
veneer of normalcy of grandpa joe
wandering around shouting at the clouds
it's not good for this country to be
talking about politics 24 hours say
that's not who we are
fighting about or even talking about
politics obsessing about politics people
looking at msnbc or fox
24 hours a day or cnn 24 hours a day
i feel like you're like you know then to
ferris bueller what are you still doing
go out like do something get out you
know
and donald trump had people talking
about donald trump including us
24 hours a day i think this return to
normalcy it cannot be overstated
there is no return to normalcy that's
the point there's no return to normalcy
but
joe biden is an effective face for a la
for for the the false return to normalcy
because the minute he is gone and if
harris is president all of this bursts
right back out into the open because she
is just terrible at this here she was
with mika now it is she
she's been using this online and it is
an obnoxious line i eat no for breakfast
i don't even know what that means
i eat no for breakfast okay but here she
was she was she was trotting out
the the feminist schtick i am woman hear
me roar or some such
and she says this line again to mika
brzezinski
and then she laughs hysterically at her
own joke i mean
oh my god democrats are so lucky that
joe biden is president that she is not
my goodness
i eat no for breakfast she waits for the
laugh
so have i been told many times during my
career
things from oh you're too young it's not
your turn
they're not ready for you um
no one like you has done it before i've
heard all of those things many times
over
the course of my career but i didn't
listen and
i would encourage anyone who's been told
that
whatever their gender to not listen
because again
don't be encumbered by the inability of
others to see the potential
of who you are i eat no for breakfast
i didn't listen this sounds very male
and successful
you'll recall this is not the first time
she's used this line she used to with
jane paulie with cbs this morning
uh this is a couple of months ago the
media my goodness i
you can't stop trying to make fetch a
thing stop trying to make kamala hair as
a thing
she's not a thing okay no one is
interested in camel hair's presidency
the only reason she was picked is
because joe biden felt that in order to
shore up the black vote he needed a
black
vp candidate he did not hide the ball on
this he said it quite openly
and so now you're stuck with this i mean
they they they're gonna have to
it's gonna be like el said they're gonna
staple joe biden to a horse and ride his
corpse around to prevent kamala harris
from becoming president she's just this
bad at this
i was raised to understand many people
will tell you
it is impossible but don't listen i
mentor a lot of people and i tell them
that there will be people who will say
it's not your turn it's not your time no
one like you has done it
and i'll tell them and don't you listen
and then i will go on to tell them i eat
no for breakfast
oh no and she's laughing at her own joke
and jane paul is going
oh okay you're not going to make hammer
harrison things they're
deeply reliant on this old codger joe
biden
right we all know this and here is the
thing the more the media do this stuff
the more the media refuse to cover the
issues that are actually at play
the more they just repeat the narratives
that are pushed by democrats
the more they are opening the door for
wait for it wait for it donald trump
okay i know i haven't mentioned trump's
name for a while you know why because he
hasn't been relevant since he left the
presidency
but there is very little doubt at this
point that there is a very good shot
that joe that donald trump runs for the
presidency again
and the case that he is going to make is
not going to be a case
based on the rigging of the vote in 2020
the case he's going to be banking
is that the entire media are a
propaganda outlet
for the democratic party and they've
been covering for radical policy and you
have been paying the price
and honestly he's gonna have a pretty
good case he's gonna say that animus for
him
meshed with animals for the american
people that the media cared less
about the american people suffering they
cared less about the truth than they did
about going after donald trump and he
has plenty of grounds to do that
between the the democratic party and the
media combining
to push a radical racial agenda that
does not comport with reality
blowing up stories that are non-stories
into major national stories in order to
press forward the narrative that america
requires deep systemic
change or whether it is the media
actively covering up
the malfeasance of china in the
in the spread of coronavirus trump is
going to say listen
they hated this was his case before and
it's twice as good now he's going to say
they hated me not because they hated me
but because they hated you or at the
very least they hated me so much that
they didn't care about you
and you paid the price the media for a
year
covered up the fact that there is a very
good shot that coronavirus leaked from a
wuhan lab
i mean absolutely covered up social
media would ban you and
suspend you if you so much as suggested
that this
lab leak theory was ria was reality
and now the media are admitting it now
that trump is gone they're admitting it
so what changed the answer is nothing
trump is gone so now they can admit the
agenda
here is jonathan carl on abc news
admitting as much he says yeah you know
what
probably we shouldn't have ignored that
because some things might have been true
even if trump said them but here's the
point
they did not give a damn about the truth
they only cared about how much they
hated trump and now the biden's in there
they still don't care about the truth
all they care about is covering their
ass so now they can come out the other
side and say well at least we were
honest when the time came we were honest
yeah bull crap
yes i think a lot of people have egg on
their face this was an idea
that was first put forward by mike
pompeo secretary of state
donald trump and look some things
may be true even if donald trump said
them
and there was because trump was saying
so much else
that was just out of control and because
he was uh
you know making a a a frankly racist
appeal talking about kung flu
and and the china virus his notion
that put forward that this may have or
he said flatly that this this came from
that lab was widely dismissed but
actually
there's some real reason we don't know
by the way we still don't know i mean
notice all the hedging there even now
members of the media can't just say it
was a reasonable theory
it's all about trump why is it all about
trump because it was never about the
truth
it was always about oppositional
politics here's the new york times david
leonard saying the same thing we never
should have killed the lab league theory
yeah you shouldn't have that's correct
but because tom cotton said it you
decided to kill the lab league theory
because
all you care about is whatever the
democratic agenda is today that's it
i think people made this mistake i think
a lot of people on the political left
and a lot of people in the media made
this mistake they said wow if tom cotton
is saying something it can't be true or
they assumed that
and that's not right tom cotton does
deal in misinformation about things like
election fraud he said some things that
are just wrong
but that doesn't mean that everything he
says is wrong and it seems like
a lot of people including a lot of
people in the media leaped to dismiss
the lab league theory because of where
it was coming from and the reality is
we don't yet know how covid started yeah
no bleep and it's not just that
okay here's the headline from the new
york times july 29 2020
from nicholas kristof the opinion
columnist help me find trump's
anarchists in portland
the president has his politically driven
narrative and then there's reality
help me find the anarchists right this
was the line i remember there were there
were journalists who literally went to
portland and they sat in the park and
they're like i don't see any anarchists
here
i don't see anything bad happening here
and because trump was focusing in on the
fact that black lives matter
was involved in violence and because he
was focusing in on the fact that black
lives matter
leadership was in fact anti-semitic and
he was focusing in on the fact they were
marxist and he was focusing in on the
fact
that the the anarchists in portland were
in fact committing acts of anarchy the
entire media decided
not to cover it and only now are they
coming out and they're like oh you know
what i guess probably we should cover it
now
article today washington post anarchists
and an increase in violent crime
hijacked portland social justice
movement quote
the church on the edge of the city was
built to hold thousands and on this
drizzly day the pews of mana house were
filled with hundreds of mourners
scattered throughout the broad high
ceiling chamber to comply with pandemic
rules
nearly all of them were black they had
gathered to memorialize
jalen joachim 33 whose body lay in a
clear casket at the front of the stage
the wounds on his face had been brushed
over a blue suit and white open collar
shirt hid the rest of his scars from the
daylight shots that killed him in a
pizza restaurant parking lot this month
portland is a white city overwhelmingly
so african americans account for just
six percent of the population
but it is black people such as yocum an
aspiring union electrician who are dying
at near historic rates and filling
churches with grief
on may 12th yokum a father of two young
boys became the city's 30th homicide
victim this year
that is five times the number recorded
during the same period in 2020 a
frightening pace that could see more
slangs here by the end of the year than
in the past four decades
after months of social justice activism
that made portland
a vivid sometimes violent focal point
for a nation debating the same issues
around police accountability and reform
the movement here has splintered into
bickering groups at odds over tactics
goals
and an overall direction for how to make
the city safer with the police force
still at the debate's
bitter center the sharpening conflict
between rising violent crime and efforts
to reduce the size of police departments
has played out
across the american west throughout this
pandemic year now cities such as
portland have retrenched so of oakland
berkeley la and several other
influential cities on the issue
the nightly confrontations with police
and federal agents deployed here by
president donald trump have been
replaced by a kind of generational
hopelessness
a tenuous sense of security across an
under-policed
city and returned to an old-school style
of gun violence reminiscent of a
tit-for-tat cycle of deadly reprisals
almost always
among young men of color oh weird but
you didn't report on this
at all for a year because to report on
it would have been to acknowledge that
trump was right
okay the same thing is happening with
regard to blm there's an entire article
in the new york times today
about how the support for black lives
matter has dropped precipitously
who do they blame well they decline
first of all
views of blm dropped across every single
racial group in america
why because it turns out the blm
protests all too often
turn into riots okay but the times
instead blames the gop
the article in the new york times by
jennifer trudy and hakeem jefferson they
say the precipitous decline in support
mirrors the increased politicization of
the issue by elites in the days and
weeks following floyd's death republican
politicians quickly turned attention
away from the actions
of a murderous police officer to those
individuals protesting the injustice
or um no actually blm riders injured
police officers
in 72 percent of cities that held blm
protests across the us and canada
according to the major cities chiefs
association the property damage cost up
to 2 billion dollars
and the riots left at least 25 people
dead including retired policeman david
dorn maybe that had something to do with
the drop in popularity
as the daily wire points out but no
according to the media only now are we
allowed to mention that blm is not all
that popular only now are we allowed to
mention that antifa is in fact a violent
group
only now are we allowed to mention that
there was chaos in portland and only now
are we allowed to mention that perhaps
this lab leak
started in wuhan and was covered up by
the chinese government because trump's
gone now
if you think that trump can't ride that
hobby horse back to the white house
let me suggest that you've got this
sucker all wrong
and that when you spend years covering
for the democratic agenda
by just referring to it as sort of the
new normal
or return to normalcy you have made a
category error
joe biden was elected by the american
people in order to restore a sense of
normalcy
he was not elected in order to
effectuate radical change and yet
he took that as a mandate to effectuate
radical change increasing the budget by
a full 50 percent
blowing out the spending to to levels we
have not seen since world war ii
he has pushed a racially polarizing
brand of politics
that has been unseen in the country
seriously for decades
and the media have covered for all of
that there is a burgeoning backlash and
it is going to hurt the democrats it is
coming for them and it should come for
them
because what they've done here is
incredibly incredibly ugly
they've castigated the systems of the
united states as racist without
reference
to what in the systems is actually
racist they've castigated americans as
racist
they've made up stories about americans
being racist without actually making
sure that there's any underlying fact to
it
and when the the image that that is
being pushed by the media is so
disconnected from the actual reality
all on the basis of we have to make hay
while the sun shines all on the basis of
we have to prop this old coot up until
he can get done what he needs to get
done
and waiting in the wings is kamala
harris i gotta say i am not optimistic
for the future of the democratic party
here over the course of the next couple
of years and neither should they be
which might be the reason why they're
pushing so hard so fast right now but
the backlash is coming
and it is well deserved alrighty we'll
be back here later today with an
additional hour of content coming up
soon the mountain wall show airs at 1 30
pm eastern be sure to check it out over
at dailywear.com i'm ben shapiro this is
the ben shapiro show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
elliot feld executive producer jeremy
boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover and our assistant director is
pavo wiedowsky
editing is by adam sciavitz audio is
mixed by mike coromina
hair and makeup is by fabiola christina
production assistant is jessica kranz
the ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2021
on the matt wall show we talk about the
things that matter real issues that
affect you
your family our country not just
politics but culture faith
current events all the fundamentals if
they matter to you come check out the
show